good evening in a landmark ruling the
Supreme Court today legalized abortions
that was then and I think that January
22nd 1973 would be an historic day this
is now the Supreme Court's Roe v Wade
decision wasn't the end of the fight
over abortion rights in the United
States it was just a bell signaling
another round in a lengthy match this
fight that we have we don't we don't
have to be having it the way that we're
having it it doesn't make much sense
proponents on both sides of abortion
accessibility have pounced out of their
corners and are ready to box it out over
the future of this issue now that
President Trump has nominated this man
for the High Court even more eyes are
fixed on roe v wade this Supreme Court
nominee judge Kavanagh is going to
destroy women's reproductive freedom if
it were to be overturned I think it
would happen in a very slow way I don't
think we'd it there'd be a big headline
one day in the paper I think rather over
a series of rulings over the course of
many years we wake up one day and
discover heck you know Roe vs. Wade was
more or less overturned hey am i me
Mayan and I'd love for you to hit that
subscribe button right now because we're
about to explain what the US would look
like in a post Rovi wave world and as it
turns out we may already have the
blueprint to that future
[Music]
this is what the United States look like
in the 1970s the Vietnam War had
generations in conflict President
Richard Nixon won reelection and just
one year later Watergate had already
begun to consume his presidency let me
remind you that the finest steel has to
go through the hottest fire and I can
assure you my friends this room is full
of fine steel tonight and when the 1970s
began women still weren't allowed to
have credit cards this was the nation's
backdrop when the Supreme Court's
historic row v Wade decision legalized
abortion but the minute it was decided
it was contested by anti-abortion
advocates in this instance the Supreme
Court has withdrawn protection for the
human rights of unborn children and it
is teaching people that abortion is a
rather innocuous procedure the decision
has been on the books now for 45 years
and today's that show one in four women
in the US will have an abortion by age
45 but a racing roe v wade isn't the way
some anti-abortion advocates do you
success instead activists like Eric
Scheidler believed throttling it is the
best way to neuter it he says people who
oppose abortion access should focus on
chipping away at the precedent by
finding ways to restrict the procedure I
think the chances of Roe vs. Wade being
reversed anytime soon are very low it
would take just the right sort of case
in just the right sort of cultural
moment I think we're far more likely to
see the Supreme Court allow further
restrictions on abortion schuyler says
cases like 1992's kcd Planned Parenthood
already have done that and he believes
they've been more impactful than wrote
in Casey the Supreme Court ruled that
states could regulate abortion to
protect the health of the mother and the
life of the fetus it affirmed most of
Pennsylvania's 1982 abortion Control Act
which required a 24-hour waiting period
before procedure and that women be given
informed consent and the pursuit for
restrictions didn't end they
if Roe ended right now 22 states are
likely to end abortion thanks in part to
trigger laws those are laws some states
have passed that say the procedure is
immediately outlawed in the event Rose
overturned the state's most likely to
eliminate access are concentrated in the
South and Midwest even right now there
are cases working their way up through
the system to help restrict Rose
precedent there are any number of
measures that the Supreme Court has
allowed over the years to restrict
abortion regulate abortion in some way
or another and the the standard that
they're using now isn't the sort of
carte blanche of abortion on demand that
we saw in Roe versus Wade Shidler admits
that even if Roe were reversed
immediately it wouldn't mean the end of
abortion access in the US the choice
would revert back to the states that's
where you'd see the difference today 42
states required licensed doctors to
perform abortions and that Pennsylvania
I mentioned earlier in total 27 states
require a woman to wait a specified
amount of time between when she receives
counseling and when the procedure occurs
author and attorney Michelle Overman
says these differences impact women
differently depending on their financial
status the correlation between abortion
and economics is crystal clear women
have abortions when they feel that they
cannot afford to have another child or
to have a child and we see that playing
out when we look at the statistics of
who has abortions in this country
the poorest thirteen percent of women in
this country have over half the
abortions in this country around 75
percent of abortion patients in 2014
were poor or low-income 59 percent had
at least one birth the way in which we
framed the debate as sort of as a
symbolic matter actually diverges pretty
dramatically from the way in which
abortion plays out Oberman who has spent
years studying the issue says
restricting abortion access
disproportionately affects the
financially insecure and adolescents
because wealthier people can afford to
travel to areas where the procedure is
available they can travel out of state
if they need to do so they can afford to
take the days off of work abortion
restrictions don't support them as much
that disparity doesn't bother Scheidler
I don't really see a problem with anyone
having difficulty getting an abortion I
think that's good I think it should be
very difficult like many people Oberman
says she once assumed that if abortion
was illegal in a country then the nation
would see fewer incidences of it
abortion rates actually are higher in
countries with the strictest laws around
the world even if abortion is completely
against the law it doesn't go away and
we know this from looking at countries
around the world like El Salvador where
abortion is completely banned with no
exceptions and the abortion rate in El
Salvador is actually higher than it is
in the United States El Salvador is a
place where abortion has been completely
outlawed since 1998 women and girls face
a prison sentence of between two and
eight years for having an abortion it's
a place where clandestine abortions are
common and where woman named Teodoro del
Carmen Vasquez spent eleven years in
jail for the still birth of her child El
Salvador is one of six Latin American
countries with total abortion bans and
generally speaking the global South has
the world's most restrictive abortion
laws the lowest abortion rates are in
North America and Europe with northern
Europe having the lowest rates many
European countries also have federally
paid family planning programs ranging
from 35 weeks to a year France gives
expectant mothers 16 weeks off Germany
allows mothers to take up to three years
off Overman believes that this type of
support for pregnant parents is what
contributes to those decreased rates of
abortion Scheidler says he'd love to see
any support that lowers the number of
procedures well I'm happy to see any
kind of measures that would assist
families that would make it more
possible for women to choose life for
their babies you know it's often made
out that you know everyone who's opposed
to abortion is you know also opposed to
health care or opposed to any kind of
program any kind of social programs and
I just don't see that to be true not
from where I'm sitting and it certainly
is in my position Scheidler has always
been anti-abortion but not always
conservative he voted for Bill Clinton
and for a decade he identified as an
atheist
and though he doesn't believe it's fair
to compare the US is abortion outlook to
countries like El Salvador he did say a
us with strict abortion laws would
probably look a lot more like Ireland
until May 2018 Ireland had a nearly
total abortion ban Ireland has a low
abortion Airi 17 per 1000 women Ireland
also has public health care and six
months paid maternity leave global
comparisons aside if Roe were reversed
there's one big reason the US wouldn't
go back to looking like it did before
the ruling the biggest change since 1973
in terms of illegal abortion is the
advent of abortion drugs
you see even in places where the
procedure is restricted if there's
internet access then there's
accessibility to abortion drugs with a
simple search but Olbermann warns that
increasing abortion restrictions will
have a tangible cost there will be women
who do die from illegal abortion though
so let's just be clear about that
because there'll be a population of
women who don't access abortion drugs so
easily or find out too late in their
pregnancy or who take the wrong drug at
the wrong dose and we also know however
we can predict who those women will be
they'll be the poorest and most
marginalized the future of reproductive
rights is threatened regardless of ropey
weights future and the truth is that for
some women in some states a united
states without abortion access is
already a reality it's just that now
many more women are at risk for being in
that same pool hey Pam thanks so much
for watching don't forget to Like share
and subscribe this is just one of the
many stories will be doing leading up to
the midterms and we want to know what
you want to see from us give us your
story ideas in the comments and we'll
see you next Sunday bye